aita a difficult uh games difficult
tournament up to this point but you're
finally on the scoreboard uh your
reaction to that how did you adjust to
these last few difficult
days yeah I've had a rough start I don't
think I've started with four losses
before um but it happens and at least
the good thing out of those games was
that I was getting good positions out of
the openings and I was just misplaying
and choosing the wrong plans at the
critical moments so you know I'm just
put all that behind me and just taking
it a game by game so just focusing on
the games
ahead do you train with somebody for
this tournament did your coach tell you
any encouraging words uh after this
losses how did you readjust to uh this
new
reality I I've just been getting advice
to like just take a game by game just to
like forget everything that has happened
so far and just to think of it as like a
for round tournament um in this middle
part of the event but just really taking
a game by game just not thinking about
what has happened in the past um and
just looking forward to the future while
still a lot of games left ashita thank
you very much for uh joining us and
we'll see you in the next few rounds
absolutely thank you uh ashria that's
the way you've got to do it it just
forget it never happened uh